the twilight movies combine for over 10
hours of run time and are chock full of
details
so today we want to place these movies
under the microscope and present the
small details throughout the series that
are easy to overlook if you aren't
paying attention
from references to the book to truly
bizarre moments
here are some things you may have missed
in the twilight movies
who are they the cullens
throughout the twilight films the colons
can be spotted wearing jewelry with
their family crest
however this detail wasn't in the books
and is exclusive to the movies
the crest includes a lion three
shamrocks and a hand
it's a cool looking item that was a nice
addition by the filmmakers
here's an odd detail that can be seen in
the beginning of the first movie
when bella and her father are driving
through town they stop at an
intersection as a truck drives by
it's a scene that looks completely
normal and unassuming at first
but if you look closely you'll notice
that the truck has no driver
we can't imagine why this is as it's a
weird and kind of creepy detail you'll
always notice now
here's another odd example of something
missing from a scene
when bella and edward are lying in the
meadow in the first movie
there's a shot where kristen stewart's
left foot appears to be
missing again we have no idea why this
would be
maybe it's an optical illusion or maybe
some post-production editing
accidentally removed the foot even
though vampires don't eat in the
twilight series
emmett can be spotted in the first film
with a big bag
full of hard-boiled eggs according to
director
catherine hardwick emmett actor kellen
lutz actually brought the eggs to set
with him
on his own i'm like okay emmett has to
have those eggs
you have to carry that in that scene
let's didn't let the eggs go to waste
either
eating them all after the scene because
i know you i know that you guys don't
eat
to ensure kristen stewart's safety
during a scene where she slips and falls
it appears that she was wearing knee
pads under her jeans
the odd thing however is that in the
scene stewart
actually falls on her butt not her knees
maybe the pads were there just for extra
safety measures
yeah i'm good ice doesn't really help
the uncoordinated twilight bucked
many of the cliche vampire stereotypes
we know they are
unharmed by garlic can walk in the sun
without burning
and appear in mirrors and images
apparently though
bella didn't get the memo on mirrors as
she has a dream where edward doesn't
have a reflection
you're not gonna let this go are you no
we get a bit of foreshadowing to jacob's
wolf form in new moon
when bella and jacob are fixing up
motorcycles we see a paw print on the
back of jacob's shirt
this is before we see him transform into
a wolf for the first time
if bella had spotted this perhaps she
wouldn't have been so surprised when he
turned
since when are you into motorcycles the
evil victoria is revealed at the end of
the first film
suspiciously looking over edward and
bella however
if you are paying attention earlier in
the scene you can actually spot victoria
at the dance
she's only on screen for a few seconds
but you can see a side profile of her
with her distinct hair and outfit don't
let him do this to us when edward and
bella first talk to each other in
biology class
they are doing an assignment on onion
cells and the teacher mentions that the
first pair to correctly complete the
assignment
wins a golden onion the scene carries on
as normal and then cuts to the hallway
where bella and edward continue their
conversation
if you're paying attention you'll notice
that bella is carrying the golden onion
meaning they won the challenge they
never bring attention to it and it's
never mentioned again
golden onion in breaking dawn part 2
jasper and alice have a plan to keep
renee safe during their fight with the
volturi
the plan is to send center with jacob
far away from the battle
alice gets them fake documents including
a license and passport
the name seen on jacob's items is jacob
wolf wolf get it because
you know he turns into a wolf yeah
there's a pretty funny blink and you'll
miss it moment
in breaking dawn part one while on their
honeymoon
bella goes into the bathroom to freshen
up this includes brushing her teeth
however when she goes to put the
toothpaste on the brush
she completely misses and squirts
toothpaste into the sink
we've all had a moment of toothpaste
trouble but it's so weird that they left
this in the scene
especially since in the next shot we see
that the toothpaste
is perfectly on her brush jacob's wolf
form and human form
are obviously very different but one
thing you would expect
might be the same is their eye color but
this isn't the case
there seems to be a discrepancy in how
brown his eyes are
in human form he has dark brown eyes
whilst in wolf form
he has lighter eyes this is a tough one
to catch
but you'll be able to see it now that
you know you don't live in the world you
think you do
twilight author stephanie meyer made an
appearance in the first twilight movie
that went
unnoticed by many she can be spotted in
the diner sitting at the counter with
her laptop out
meyer was actually reluctant to do this
cameo and didn't want it to be so
obvious
i was thinking it was going to be more
like a where's waldo thing
like i walk by for one second in a crowd
and if they can find me
cool apparently she was talked into it
again as she also appeared at bella and
edward's wedding
here's your veggie plate stop me when
edward and bella are in the cafeteria
bella knocks over an apple which edward
catches and holds out for her
which mimics the twilight book cover
it's a nice nod to the iconic imagery on
the cover of the popular novel
after jasper's outburst towards bella's
blood carlisle patches bella up
when he's done he made sure to burn the
bloody gauze to get rid of the smell of
blood
the red of the blood and the white of
the gauze creatively represent the image
on the cover of the new moon book
which is a white and red flower this
book cover representation in the eclipse
movie is a bit more abstract
and again uses blood to conjure the
image the eclipse book cover
features an image of a red ribbon that
runs across the length of the book
during the climactic battle against
victoria bella cuts her arm to distract
the evil vampires
and the blood running down her arm is an
homage to the red ribbon
image the breaking dawn book cover
reference
is one of the easier ones to spot when
bella and edward play chess during their
honeymoon
they use a very familiar chess set a
black and white board with white and red
pieces which is exactly the kind that is
on the cover of the book
it's a nice reference to the final book
of this saga
every time we see a wolf transformation
in the movies
the character's clothes are completely
shredded in the process
perhaps it's the reason they are
shirtless so often
but still they waste a lot of clothing
there is actually
one time someone does take off their
clothes when jacob shows charlie his
wolf form in breaking dawn part 2
he strips down beforehand better late
than never i guess
jacob put your clothes on robert
pattinson is a man of
many talents and one of those is his
musical chops
in the first twilight movie as well as
in breaking dawn part 2
pattinson is actually playing the piano
on top of this
he also has two original songs on the
twilight movie soundtrack
pattinson does it all bella can be
spotted wearing the same ring and
bracelets throughout the movies
she has the moon ring her mother gave
her in the first movie on her right
pointer finger
and bracelets on both wrists we know
kristen stewart is as much a fan of the
jewelry as her character is
as steward took the ring with her from
set after filming
this is my mother's we love how much
detail went into the twilight franchise
these movies are full of fun quirky
moments that give you something new to
find on each re-watch
so be on the lookout the next time you
dive back into this vampire epic
did you catch any of these details
during your viewings of the films